hello and welcome back to the road to
2000s as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I'm your driver on this journey
today it's gonna be a fun one I wanted
to take a look at an opening that I like
a lot it might be my favorite opening in
chess it's one I've had pretty good
success with and it's one I hope I can
you know share the success with you that
opening is the Kings Indian defense from
the white side I wanted to show you some
games that I took inspiration from in my
opening repertoire and hopefully go over
a lot of the main ideas in this opening
hopefully by the end you guys will all
be masters at it and can crush the
King's Indian because it's a very fun
opening to play with with both sides
this first game I wanted to take a look
at is the game between Wesley so and
Engler n they played this I think a
couple years ago now and it is I think
one of the most topical lines in the
main main line of the classical Kings
Indian for a long time people played
this opening you know a certain way and
then eventually they were like wow this
this isn't really working I keep getting
checkmated as white and then a couple a
few years back they came up with this
pawn sacrifice line that I wanted to go
over and this is the line that that I
use and this is the line that's good
enough for Wesley so so it's good enough
for me so let's take a look the King's
Indian of course starts after d4 Knight
f6 c4g 693 Bishop g7 II or d6 of course
in this position you know white black
can play d5 and that's a Grune felled
after Bishop g7 he's really committing
to this Kings Indian defense setup and
that's why I play e4 here's white to
take away this option of ever playing d5
as such black then ops for more dark
square strategy by playing d6 conceding
the d5 square and playing for these dark
squares instead it's a common idea
Knight f3 castles Bishop e2 so this is
the classical way of playing the Kings
Indian defense as white you develop your
Knights to the classical squares you
push your pawns
to the classical squares you develop
your Bishop you castle your King
everything kind of done classically I
don't know if that's where the name
comes from but it's kind of you know
your standard chess you could do
everything you want to do in the opening
you just develop your pieces control the
center meanwhile black plays a five
which is you know L at first glance a
counterintuitive move blocking off your
own Bishop but like I said black is
really playing for the dark squares in
this opening as white you don't really
want to flinch just yet and do anything
in the center a common line is to
actually take on e5 which is leading to
an end game which has been tried for an
advantage for white but it's not my
favorite and I think black has totally
fine chances as such the classical line
continues with King side castles and in
this first game I want to look at knight
c6 this is move seven and this is where
I'll kind of be branching off today so
this is kind of our starting point for
today Black has done the Kings Indian
set up but as Bishop on g7 his knight on
f6 and this d65 moves these are these
pawn moves and from here blacks going to
decide how we really wants to play this
game the main line is the line we're
looking at in this game which happens
after knight c6 really a hammering home
this idea of attacking the d4 square the
other two options I'm going to take a
look at come after Knight to a6 kind of
counterintuitive move but the knight is
aiming at some key squares such as b4 +
c5 or Knight B to d7 this is the other
move I'm going to look at today also
aiming for this c5 square in this game
though ding Lauren played the classical
move Knight to c6 and of course now
white does have to make a decision about
this pawn you can try to defend it one
more time you can now decide to take on
e5 or you can push this pawn these are
all viable options but the one I'm going
to go over today is pawn to d5 this is
my pick and this is kind of the most
critical line of course this Knight has
to move so the knight comes back to e7
and now once again white has quite a few
options and the move I'm picking to look
at is Knight to e1 so for a long time
this was the way to play
as white in the Kings Indian obviously
there are a ton of different things you
can do but this is one of the most
popular lines at the top level and it
still is one of the most popular lines
today are you guys at all familiar with
this position have you guys seen this
before yep
not necessarily we're gonna take a look
at this today where black actually gets
everything he wants on the Kings side
but the point is white gets everything
that he wants on the Queen side and it's
kind of this the style of race that
characterizes this position so what do I
mean let me explain a little bit more so
you've probably been told to play on the
side where you have more space and that
definitely rings true here in this case
black has more space on the Kings side
you can tell this because this is the
direction that his pawns point so what
is black going to do he's going to
expand further on the Kings side ken you
mentioned that this pawn will come
forward to f5 and possibly to f4 and
this is something that White has to
worry about is black launching this pawn
forward and actually we'll see later on
in the game black actually launches the
rest of these pawns forward too and so
with that in mind
black ends all this space with ease with
his pawns gets right up next to the
white king and then tries to go for
checkmate so this is why this line is so
fun is if you're the white player well
if you're the black player it's fun
because you get to checkmate white a lot
but if you're the white player it's fun
because while black is having all this
fun on the Kings side you get to have
just as much fun on the Queen side so
this is really I think the most stark
example in chess of the players kind of
playing on opposite sides of the board
and truly just ignoring each other for
as long as possible which makes it fun
it's like a race to be checkmated or to
win on the Queen side so that's going to
be the theme of the game that's going to
be the theme of a lot of positions we
look at today is black playing on the
Kings side and white trying to play on
the Queen side so continuing on here
Knight to d7
this move makes a lot of sense one he's
preparing to launch this F pawn forward
and to this pawn is controlling a key
square in the black camp
well while black is playing for F 5 F
for white is usually playing for
something involving you know these dark
squares getting this pawn to c5 white
simply develops his Bishop you know
controlling these skirt key squares
black launches the pawn forward white
needs to play f3 to defend this pawn and
give us bishop space and black plays
naturally with f4 and our bishops
attacks so Bishop F to g5 very natural
for black and this is all technically
theory but it's not actually that much
theory to have to learn to play this
opening it's all very linear meaning
there's not a lot of branching paths
because you really just want to plan on
the Kings side if you're black and you
need to make these defensive moves for
white and then you just launch your
attack on the Queen side so g5 is the
next move for black to continue and here
is where once again there are a few
branching paths for white so it's kind
of tough as the black player in this
instance because White has so many
different ways to kind of play but here
I'm gonna recommend the most popular
move rook to c1 this is what Wesley slow
played in this game and I think it's the
most interesting line so after Knight to
g6 this is where things start getting
interesting so for a long time players
wanted to play moves like Knight d3
instead of Rick to see one and kind of
play this the slow way defend this c5
square then push the pawn forward then
try to open it up but this is actually a
very very interesting line here if white
plays pawn to c5 immediately so this
move doesn't look like it makes too much
sense right away right
you know black can just capture this
pawn
but what do you think White's idea is
here and this is the main line this is
the way blacks should play
yeah
yeah
so you're on the right track right
you're looking for ways to rip open this
side of the board just move the knight
to b5 first that's also a possibility
here so your knee-jerk reaction was to
capture which is good you should look at
those moves first and after pawn takes
you wanted to play something like Knight
b5 trying to you know open up some
attack get these pieces in the game and
well this is interesting
I don't think it's it's quite working
here just yet yeah something like a six
actually looks quite good you don't
really want to bring the knight all the
way back here you'd rather have this you
know attacking option with the rook but
maybe just something like B six maybe
even b5 maybe even something like I
don't know c6 these all seem kind of
possible if you're black yeah the white
knight does look silly but really that
the key feature here is white is really
missing this bishop suspicious is a
really nice defender of the King side
and it can really attack a lot of
squares long distance and so it's a
pretty big commitment to give up this
guy you want to be sure you're getting
really something good for it so it's
actually not to capture the night when
Mom Knight d5 is interesting I don't
think this is quite correct either again
probably because of this a six month
mm-hmm so any other ideas
now all right well somebody in the
YouTube chat has an interesting idea
they said before here yeah so this is a
pretty natural move as well you've drawn
this Knight to this square sacrificing a
pawn and then you kick it back
immediately
which looks a little strange but the
point is you're gaining a lot of time
against this Knight you're opening
things up so this opening line would it
be very good if black could come back to
d7
if black could come back to d7 and be
just fine then honestly I don't think
this pawn sack makes much sense but
fortunately for white black can't go
back to d7 because of White's next move
yeah so this should be five this is a
playable move but well I don't know it
doesn't look very good to me
the reason for that being the square is
kind of important for a different piece
first of all and second of all well you
do want to be playing on the queenside
you don't really want to be drawing away
defenders from your king and this Bishop
is actually a very important offender
because the really relevant square and
this position is g4 if we give blacks
some time he loved to put his knight
here and then push this pawn forward and
push g4 this is what black is really
playing for is expanding like this on
the Kings side bringing this pawn
forward and really pressuring the white
king with that of Mines and this Bishop
does a really nice job of defending this
g4 square stopping black from you know
pushing this quite so early so any other
ideas here and that was one we want to
start making some threats
what do you think you had it before ken
you had it before we just looked at that
Audi we just looked at Bishop e5
oh okay so we just looked at this we
don't want to bring this Bishop away
from our King and it doesn't do a whole
lot on b5 but maybe another piece could
do what something on b5 Navy
oh yeah the knight Knight b5 excellent
move so in this case Knight b5 is
actually just winning and the reason for
that is there's no way to defend this
pawn this is why you can't bring the
knight back to d7 if the knight isn't
here you would love to play rook f7
simply defending this pawn but that's
simply not not possible in this case so
black might make some move and then the
news gets worse for black after Knight
takes c7 rook b8 there's simply Bishop
takes a seven and this this Rick is
stuck and so black is still gonna have
some you know stupid attack on the Kings
side and probably checkmate you anyways
but what white is totally winning here
white is just going to take this rook
bring this Knight to this square yeah
yeah yeah the rook is trapped we don't
even have to take it right away so this
would be you know winning for white
which is why this line kind of works
after b4 you can't bring this Knight
back naturally to the Kings side you
have to play the unnatural looking
Knight to a6 to keep this square
defended and this is really the the crux
of this opening line of this pawn
sacrifice is black's knight is going to
be horribly misplaced and we're going to
say that really slows down your attack
and it gives me enough time to do
something on the Queen side so let's
take a look at it how does white
continue white plays Knight to d3 very
simple just defending this be for square
pawn rather black plays h5 again you're
gonna see these players really commit to
their plans the knight comes up to b5
threatening to capture on a7
so black responds with b6 and I think
this is where ding Lorenz started to go
wrong this is something you kind of just
have to get a feel for playing the Kings
Indian positions a lot there's some
moves that you just have to give your
opponent right White has such a crushing
space advantage on the on the Queen side
that black is not going to be able to
stop every threat that happens you're
gonna have to give something up at some
point in the game and similarly white
our Black has such a crushing space
advantage on the Kings side that you
know White is gonna have to give
something up on the Kings side
eventually so it's all a matter of
deciding what's important and what's not
in this case this a pawn
wasn't as important as black made it out
to be playing d6
further weakens this pawn it kind of
weakens this diagonal and while it shuts
off this Bishop it's it's too much of a
waste of time I think so in my opinion
this is where ding Larenz started to go
wrong it's not like he's losing or
anything but it's just it doesn't feel
quite right it's not really in the
spirit here white actually plays Bishop
II one so what do you think white is
trying to do here it's kind of
interesting
this should be one looks pretty
unnatural this is actually a maneuver
that's seen in a few lines in the Kings
Indian
so for one it makes sense to move this
bishop now black spent this whole tempo
to kind of block off our bishop
so this diagonal isn't the diagonal it
used to be it used to be great we were
attacking a7 after b6 it's not so great
so you know Wesley moves his Bishop here
it serves a purpose defending his pawn
but more importantly it's another case
of another piece being better on a
square the bishop
wasn't that actually that great on f2
however if we were to put a knight on f2
it would serve a very important purpose
why would we want a knight on f2 what
does it do
it controls g4 that's right it's all
about this g4 square in this opening
line so the main point of Bishop e1 is
yes it helps defend this pawn it gets
the bishop on a different diagonal but
the main point is it allows this knight
to come to f2 where it can slow down
blacks attack and black is really going
to be missing this night we'll see you
later in the game
if this Knight we're on f6 then g4 would
be so much easier to achieve without
that night it really is going to be
tough
black continues with rook f7 it's a
common move preparing to move this
Bishop either to f8 or a h6 and then
bring this rook in behind to support g4
simply Bishop d2 Bishop f6 and now
Knight f2 so white completes this
maneuver in the meantime black plays
Queen to e8 not the most natural-looking
move but we'll see
you know this Bishop has kind of taken
over this diagonal so the Queen might
want to come out along this diagonal I
think this was the the basis of blacks
thinking it also puts some pressure on
this night and that's why we see white
play Queen a4 here supporting this
Knight and you know adding more threats
to the Queen side Bishop d8 and Queen a3
so I want to talk a little bit about the
this Queen maneuver that Wesley did so
it's you know it's not you know entirely
unclear why it would be favorable to
have the Queen on the Queen side you
know attacking you know like this pawn
putting pressure on this file putting
pressure on this night but what let's
white get away with this is the fact
that blacks night is so sidelines you
usually don't see this Queen leaving the
d1 square in this opening line usually
it's stuck here for the exact reason
that we were talking about you know it
wants to defend against g4 but with this
night so far out of play unable to come
to f6 to support this wait doesn't have
to worry so much about it which is why
this line is pretty nice to play for
white you don't have to worry as much
about g4 you have some freedom to move
your pieces around with that in mind so
Queen a3 also moving the Queen from a
four to A three steps out of this pin
and adds some third rank defense which
is useful once these pawns do get
rolling we see g4 so now this is
actually kind of a pawn sacrifice F
takes G H takes G and white can't take
here thanks to this pressure from the
Queen
so not a true pawn sacrifice in this
case white simply plays Knight c3 first
removing this Knight from danger the
knight takes on b4 and the Queen takes
on b4 so now rather than kind of play
blacks position dinkler n decided he was
going to sacrifice this Knight in order
to get his plan through but already I
think this kind of shows y b6 might have
not been the best move and so what do I
mean by that I mean black spends a tempo
here to save this pawn he spends one
tempo to save this pawn and then later
on down the line he gives up a full
night for one tempo
does that kind of make sense so he's
spending one the tempo that he saved by
the tempo that he lost by playing b6
he's exchanging that for a night which
doesn't make the most sense to me I
would rather give up this a 7-pound than
my night with that of Mines black can't
play something like night b8 here
because then we would actually just
capture this pawn and if black loses the
g4 pawn he loses a lot of his attacking
potential so this was the decision that
ding lurin had to make here he could try
to play normally and you know move his
rook to g7 moved this Knight to h4 try
to play g4 but he decided that simply
wasn't going to work in this case
because this night is so far sidelined
so you can kind of see how this line
really puts black in into a tough spot
black has to make these really tough
decisions where if he just carries on
business as usual it's not really gonna
work out for him you really need this
night for this this plan to kind of work
so you have to get kind of creative and
do things like sacrifice however this is
not altogether terrible for black you
know this is still a very interesting
game and so let's see what Wesley did to
finish it off not that we're anywhere
near that yet so black gets to play f3
once again you see the importance of
this G pawn it supports pawn breaks like
this to rip open the King this should be
five Queen e7 and g3 so white wants to
keep the Kings side locked at all costs
it'd be a huge mistake to do something
like pawn takes pawn here I can't even
decide whether I would do this or this
or something like Knight h4 but you have
to keep your king as defended as you can
so we see g3 this Rick comes to h7
white simply plays Queen to c4 once
again not worrying too much about what
blacks doing because he has another very
interesting very useful move to really
lock down the Kings side which we'll see
in a second through it comes to h8 the
Queen comes to c6
so he's invading with this pieces on the
Queen side Queen to h7 and now this is
this might be the the move of the game
to take away the move of the game who
can find the move of the game and really
Wesley found it like five moves ago when
he realized he could ignore this
you're gonna kind of find it by
elimination almost all your moves get
checkmated its to find the ones that
don't it's my advice to you so okay you
can give this check but actually blacks
just gonna move out of the way now your
Queens attacks and you're getting
checkmated that's rough that's rough
Knight takes G for so this does the fun
checkmate and but it does sacrifice your
knight back and I'm not sure what's
going on here I think I would rather be
black because I would be afraid with
white but yeah white doesn't need to
give up this Knight actually the YouTube
chat is torn hi welcome
so what can white do to prevent me I'll
let you guys come up with a one or two
more ideas h4 so that's a really good
idea and you're on the side of most of
the YouTube viewers
however the YouTube viewers are mostly
wrong so what's the problem with h4 what
do you think yeah if you put this pawn
somewhere black can take it black is
just gonna I don't know how he's gonna
take it but he's gonna take it probably
with the night and it's gonna come
crashing through and then you have all
the same problems with zero puns in
front of your King now because of that
Wesley played the better way to block
off this file with h3 so I do want to
mention congratulations to Penta Cal
pants ikaw the only player in the
YouTube chat to give h3 yeah so it looks
pretty unnatural right you're putting
this pawn on a square where it can just
be captured but what do you think the
idea is what does white do after black
takes this pawn exactly in fact yes to
do something pretty immediately
otherwise it's still bad yeah ducha King
on h2 that's right so King h2 and this
is a stellar defensive setup for white
this is something you might have seen
before
in other positions where you use your
opponent's upon to really blockade in
your King it's you know White's best
defender is the pawn on h3 I think
that's fair to say yes so this pawn
keeps out this bishop this Queen and
this rook
so if black could take off this pawn he
would win immediately but fortunately
that's not allowed in chess so this is a
very very interesting idea that that
Wesley came up with here in the game and
I think it's one that can be used in
different types of positions in the
King's Indian
it's a very useful one to remember you
always want to be looking for these
creative ways to really block down or at
least slow down your opponent's attack
yeah yeah that's right
so captures aren't forced that's right
so H 3 a stellar move and it's really
more impressive because as soon as
Wesley played g3 I think he already knew
what he was going to do with this h3
move cuz the most obvious plan for black
is of course this this idea where you
just you know double on the H file and
give checkmate and so not only does
Wesley see that there but you can tell
he sees it here because he just ignores
everything black is doing until the last
moment he just gets his Queen in
nonchalantly you know ignoring Korean h7
and then hits them with h3 so yeah this
move I think is the move of the game so
black doesn't actually take here because
that would really shut down the file for
good he wants to keep options open
someday he wants to take this pawn with
some other piece but not upon so he
plays rook b8 saving his rook Knight
back to d1 so now we see kind of a Rima
nuvaring of white which Wesley does very
skillful skillfully here but the nice
thing about the King's Indian is if you
really slow down blacks attack on the
Kings side you winning on the Queen side
is almost inevitable meaning you just
have way too much space your pieces are
way too strong you should always be able
to find some way to kind of kind of
knock down knock down the front door but
of course a you know I mean if you're
playing digging around you have to play
accurately too so a6 is played white
actually goes for Queen e8 here which is
a little strange considering we said
after King g7 this Queen looks almost
trapped but here's what makes this game
really special is Wesley takes on d8 so
what's going on here well it's exactly
what it seems white is losing his Queen
rook takes d8 rook takes c7 Bishop takes
Bishop d7 rook takes Bishop takes and at
the end of the day let's count the
pieces
one night - one night one rook
- one rook one Queen for two bishops
and a knight and black is up upon so
white has these three pieces for this
Queen and this is what you know really
really seals the deal for this game
makes it a special one is white just
proceeds to completely out play the
Queen almost immediately yeah yeah the
bishop pair killing the Queen mm okay
so black finally says all right fine
well - I'll take your stupid pawn black
or white plays King age - definitely not
capturing this pawn even if it is free
rook b7 the bishop just comes to e6
Knight f8 Bishop f5 point h5 Knight g4
and the the end is nearing here actually
so 97 so at this point black is actually
still kind of in the game
he's definitely worse but if you can
find some way to maybe sacrifice this
rook for for one of the minor pieces to
open things up for his pawns he has some
kind of chances I think but it's I don't
know this is a very very difficult
position to play with black against all
these pieces so 97 but this runs into
Bishop h6 check forcing the King back to
h8 now the second night enters the game
rook c7 but the counter play isn't
enough after Bishop takes rook takes
rook f5 and now we see the the clear
endgame of the three pieces yeah so we
see actually some some very weird
looking coordination between all these
pieces this Knight kind of centrally
holding everything down in this night
for backup in this pawn as well in this
Bishop III honestly I don't think I've
seen many things like this in chess but
it's super interesting and it's in fact
I think just winning for White Queen f7
Bishop g5
b5 Knight h6 so we see once again Wesley
so he's so good at chess he really uh
just masterfully uses the pieces here to
get this pawn down the board it's
important to notice Queen g5 isn't doing
anything you might think it's attacking
this bishop and if this bishop moves
I'll take you Knight but in reality I
can just play f6 here taking advantage
of this unfortunate placement of your
pieces so yeah once again Wesley has it
all under control
Queen f8 f6 King h7 Knight f5 King g6
Bishop h4e for f7 III Bishop e7 e 2 and
now we simply check take the queen black
gets a new one but it's not enough more
technique and then here black actually
resigned and Wesley still won the game
so this is a super crazy game this is
one of my favourite games of chess
actually because you know Wesley really
outplayed sting her end in every stage
of the game so yeah Wesley was playing
against Engler n mmhmm yeah definitely
no slouch now you know solidly the
number 3 player in the world over 2800
Engler and a true superstar of chess but
he kind of got demolished this game he
kind of got demolished any questions
about this game there was a lot to kind
of cover there I'll go back over the key
points in a second
No all right that's fair I I still have
questions about this game and I'll never
stop having questions but that's fine
the main points black is playing for the
dark squares in the center which is what
forces white to go for this kind of
setup we see the night come back to e1
this is in an effort to prevent this
night from kind of advancing and allow
this F on some mobility and Bishop e3
and f5 f3 f4 bishop f2 so now we see the
dynamic white points as pieces at the
Queen side black points as pieces at the
Kings side and we're gonna see some kind
of race for checkmate or to win on the
Queen side the key start of the line is
after c5 and gamba ding upon black will
play Knight takes d takes is not so good
because we get something similar so what
happened in Knight takes Bishop takes
but I get to keep my Bishop this time
right so it's a lot better so Knight
takes b4 is the main point and now
Knight d7 is not possible due to Knight
b5 which is why we see Knight a 6 and
the dynamic of the game from here on out
is white says your plan with g4 is going
to be way too slow because you've been
forced to sideline your night to a6 and
meanwhile black is going to say I think
I could get g4 in anyway and my knight
on a 6 is kind of keeping your pieces
out of the game just fast forward we saw
b6 which I don't think is the best idea
for placket it kind of wastes the tempo
at a critical moment we see this
maneuver with the knight coming to f2
supporting g4 we see this Queen coming
to a3 putting pressure on the weeknight
and then we see black eventually caving
in playing g4 anyways with the idea of
playing a piece sacrifice and last but
not least the move of the game h3
keeping blacks pieces out of the game
and then the rest was just Wesley so
being Wesley so I'm not going to tell
you to try to emulate this because I
don't think many people in the world
could with you know these amazing Queen
sacrifices and peace maneuvering and
coordination that's just Wesley so being
Wesley so
so again the main points the c5 pawn
sacrifice is to sideline the knight
white attacks on the queenside
black attacks on the Kings side and
whoever gets there first is is kind of
the winner all right
let's take a look at a little bit more
of a tamer line now I think we might not
have time to get to the third line which
is fine so once again we're gonna look
at all the same opening moves the basic
Kings Indian moves but here instead of
playing a5 let's look at what happens if
black plays Knight a6 so once again the
idea is you want to attack this c5
square and at some lens you want to come
to b4 we see white can continue
naturally just by castling and E 5 and
now white actually has a lot of options
here you can play d5 I don't think it's
the best Bishop e3 is a very common move
and then the move I'm going to recommend
is rook e1 simply bringing the rook to
the file to help control the center rook
e1 was played in this game and sorry I
forgot to mention this is Daniel
Freedman against dear goose you say
enough with the black pieces
so Ricky won this bishop comes to g4 in
this game and this is actually a line
that my my friend plays and okay little
bug and lay chest here but that's fine
okay so Bishop g4 so this really
highlights the dark square method for
black so black is saying I will control
the dark squares by any means necessary
including giving up this important
bishop on the white squares for this
knight which controls these dark squares
and this is an idea that you see in a
few lines in the King's Indian with that
ax mines you know white plays Bishop to
e3
this move is even better now because
black can't chase it away with this
Knight on g4 ever we see Bishop takes
effort we don't
sometimes we see Bishop takes f3 we see
that later in this game rook e8 first d5
Knight c5 and now we see h3
Bishop takes f3 Bishop takes f3 so how
do you think this game defers from the
first game that we looked at how is this
line different
yeah there's no pawn storm yet for black
so blacks kind of saying I'm not I'm not
gonna not gonna rush things with this
just yet what's different from the white
point of view besides you know I'm
missing the night
yeah okay so we left the Queen back here
in this game I think a lot of the main
differences are we push this pawn
forward and this is kind of comital we
saw in the in the last games you know
black is playing G forward to play
against the f3 pawn here now h3 is also
kind of going to be a hook in addition
to that black has put this knight on c5
this is something we didn't really see
in the last game until we made black put
his knight on the C 5 and so the
difference here is black is really going
to play to keep this knight solidified
on c5 he plays a5 to stop b4 from
kicking his Knight away so in this line
black takes a more defensive kind of
approach that's what I would call it at
least defensive meaning he's playing
against White's plan on the Queen side
more than he is just ignoring it and
trying to checkmate on the Kings side
he's playing moves like a 5 and Knight
c5 kind of blockading the Queen side
while still pressuring the center so
blacks play is different because it's
more based around the center and
preventing White's plan rather than
solely just going for checkmate
meanwhile from the white side his plan
is going to largely be the same he still
wants to play on the Queen's side it's
just gonna have to happen a little bit
differently because black is really
trying to stop it here white simply
plays Queen c2 defending the e4 pawn
Knight FD 7 is played and now b3 is
played what do you guys think about this
smooth this might strike you as a little
strange
um okay you think it's playing against
something like Knight b6 defending this
pawn any other reasons why b3 might have
been played it's a little paradoxical
what if I told you he played b3 because
he wants to play b4
would that make sense he played b3
because he wants to play b4
so okay you obviously can't just play
before here immediately flex gonna take
it that was the whole point of the safe
five move so what's the most natural way
to try to get before in what's the most
natural way to support it so sure you
can use the rook but we'd really love to
take back with a pawn here to kick this
night away right the point yeah the
point of b4 is to kick this night away
it's not so it is to open lines but the
main point is getting rid of this
annoying night so white would love to
play a three but then if we follow down
this thinking process there's this
annoying rule in chess called on passant
and after a four we can never take back
on b4 with the pawn because black
actually takes on b3 and so if we were
to play a3 a4 would really lock down the
Queen side for black this would really
put a huge huge stop to White's Queen
side pawn storms so the solution this is
to play b3 because you want to play b4
black plays some move and now when you
play a three you have more options after
a four one of them being b4 of course in
the game we saw a four and in this case
black actually is playing this as a pawn
sacrifice allowing us to take this pawn
and if we count the defenders and
attackers we're clear and with that of
Mines b4 still would have been an option
for white and this is how a lot of games
go is you know why it ends up playing
this this b4 move here but the
difference here is that black sacrificed
upon and white decided you want it upon
of course let's take a look at what
happens if black ignores us on the Queen
side and plays an annoying move like f4
what do you guys think about this move
here
what would you do would you retreat the
bishop or take on c5 or find some
mysterious tactic that I don't see
you would retreat the bishop so that's
yeah that that would that would be fine
I agree I think here the reason why
black didn't play this because he was
worried about the time he wanted to play
a four to really force White's hand on
the Queen side now if white were to play
before maybe this night could come in to
b3 and use this as a home there's some
kind of sacrifice to always worry about
but maybe this if this Knight can land
on d4 black is going to be happy so I
think that's why I played a a four on
the other hands if we play f4 and white
uses this time to force blacks hands
into gaining a tempo by capturing here
now if we play before this night doesn't
have this this extra option I think this
is what black was worried about in the
game I don't know if this is entirely
unplayable for black I think this is
something you could have tried but
White's plans would really be
accelerated if he were allowed to do
something like this once again this
bishop on e3 is very important so you
know it takes a lot to give it up
but I think this is a case where it
would be worth it but okay in the game
we saw a four and Knight takes a four
night a four pawn a four pawn takes on
e4 was played here I don't think it
makes as much sense to play f4 anymore
the reason for that being you're really
locking this Bishop out of the game kind
of for all of eternity
so black takes on e4 with the idea that
maybe someday this this pawn will move
out of the way and this Bishop can
breathe or maybe someday the bishop will
come to this diagonal if this bishop
gets say you know diverted from here we
saw b6 trying again to play for the dark
squares rook a b1 excuse me
Rick a7 Bishop d2
Queeny seven rook b5 so once again white
is really playing on the Queen side here
and I think already white white is much
much better the reason for that Bing
black obviously didn't go as hard on the
Kings side this game right he didn't try
as hard to go for these these checkmates
and as such his play over here it has
kind of completely stalled black is
really playing white's game on the Queen
side he's really you know putting all of
his marbles on this night being really
good on c5 but it's just not enough to
make up for you know the deficiencies in
his position that the lack of space the
pawn breaks that white has they really
are what decide this game you see Bishop
f6 and now a5 is of course the the great
pawn brick the bishop comes to g5 so at
this point black is working really hard
to fix his horrible pieces but in the
meantime you know white is making a lot
of progress on the Queen side Bishop
comes to be for King comes to g7 pawn
number two rolls up the board
Rick ei eights take some b6 take some b6
simply wreck a one and you can see that
white is really giving up nothing and
he's still up upon and he's still going
to have you know plenty of ideas on this
Queen side Queen f8 Queen d1 bishop d8
Rick a three-night c5 rook f3 and then
you know blacks whole point of this
opening was to have a really good night
on c5 and so white simply captures it
and we see Bishop c2 Bishop a5 simply g3
and a little on down the road at the end
of the day white is simply up a pawn and
black doesn't have much to show for it
so we get to this end game in which a
lot of moves are played which I'm going
through very quickly and now white is up
two pawns and manages to convert this
somehow someway black just resigns here
this bishop is not enough to cover both
of these pawns on files so far away this
final position is actually zooms along
by the way the black King has to move
away or the black bishop has to move
away either from f6 or from a5 and so
this is just winning for white I scroll
through the last part of that game
pretty darn quickly there but any
questions about this game what went
wrong for black what went well for white
what do you think
nothing yeah
he didn't get any Kings side play I
think that's a lot of what went wrong
he kind of half-heartedly played a well
I don't know if he played it
half-heartedly maybe he played it with a
lot of authority but he played f5 and
then this didn't really develop into
anything he spent a lot of time trying
to stop White's play on the Queen side
but once again if you spend too much
time on the side where your opponent is
strong your opponent will always be able
to break through you want to be playing
on the side where you're strong more
often than not so I think yeah what
weren't wrong was this a four pawn
sacrifice didn't really get the job done
it didn't really do it for me as well as
some of this maneuvering I just think it
wasn't the best for black so okay so
yeah black didn't get enough play on the
Kings side I think is the short way to
describe it so in the remaining time I'm
gonna see if I can get through this
third game between the one and only
Boris Gelfand and Vasily Ivanchuk so
this was the last kind of way to play
that I wanted to look at and it's with
Knight B to d7 rather than this Knight
to c6 so this is kind of the starting
position I wanted to look at so what do
you think the differences are here but
this Knight on g7 rather than being on
c6
what do you think
fifty-five
yeah one difference for white is that
when you push d5 you're not attacking
anything so it's a lot less appealing
but the counterpart to this is that with
the knight on c6 black is forcing you to
push d5 because he's putting so much
pressure on this EEP deep on so because
in this game whoops
because in this game black didn't put so
much pressure on d4 we don't have to
move it right away and in fact we don't
want to just why it white actually plays
Bishop III here so what's there should
be like one move that really sticks out
to you whenever you see Bishop III
played in positions like this do you
guys know what move that is yeah Knight
g4 should stick out white added the
defender to d4 but it can't really stay
there cuz Knight g4 you know attacks
this bishop and makes it move in this
case this is a fine opening line for
black but this is just you know another
way to play I think this bishop comes to
g5 this pawn comes to f6 Bishop comes
back to d2 and then maybe this Knight is
a little bit misplaced but okay in this
game black didn't want to play like that
so black just plays c6 and now that
black has made kind of some hook for us
to latch on to white actually plays d5
because in this case you know white now
has options whenever he wants to try to
open this this D file and attack this
deep on black decided he didn't like
that so he played c5 and now we kind of
reached the main structure of this game
we see c4 d v e4 against d6 c v e5 is
this something you guys are kind of
familiar with something you've seen yeah
so what do you think the differences are
here compared to those first games we
looked at what's different about this
structure
doing the structures better for black
than the last structure or worse for
black than the last structure yeah I
agree
I think this structure is a lot more
solid for black altogether you're
preventing the c5 break this is really
huge huge for black what can still find
play on the queenside by is doing
something like b4 and taking here but
it's gonna be a lot less threatening
then when white was going to play c5 so
what is black given up for this for this
favorable change in structure what did
black have to give up
well yeah what do you mean by that he
gave up some other kind of advantage for
this structural advantage well no he
actually space is one way to phrase it
but I think he might have less space
with this pawn on c7 right
the structure is favorable because he
has more space he gave up space in the
sense that this night couldn't come to
c6 first but in the end that night came
back to e7 maybe he's giving up space
because this night would like to go to
d7 but now it can't so in a sense some
space but that's not the huge thing
so the huge thing that he gave up is
time he played c6 and then c5 as well as
developing this night to sub-optimal
square meaning he's gonna have to you
know shuffle his pieces around a little
bit to get his plan going so he gave up
a lot of time in this position so that's
what Wyatt really wants to play for here
he wants to use his advantage in time to
get something immediate some immediate
advantage back and let's see what white
did in this game here he played 91 in
the same maneuver that we talked about
so first off he's preventing this Knight
from advancing forcing it to go back to
maybe a suboptimal square on e8 like we
said this night would like to go to d7
maybe but you know his his friend is in
the way so ninety eight and now yeah
this is I think the the main move for
for this opening this is what really
showed bors's understanding here let's
show an example line first to maybe help
you find it so if we do nothing if we
play rook b1 trying to play b4 black is
going to play f5 if we play our normal
f3 and f4 Bishop f2 g5 we've seen this
type of stuff before right this looks
very very familiar but the difference
here of course is that we don't ever
have this option this option is just not
available to us we can play things like
b4 and take on c5 but in the end this
this really isn't enough this isn't
enough to warrant you know playing this
this this isn't enough advantage on the
Queen side two weren't the attack on the
Kings side that black is going to get is
what I'm saying you need more than this
so white came up with something to do
besides trying to play on the Queen side
and he's allowed to do this thanks to
his advantage in time
hey Michael
yeah wait to move and prevent blacks
plan so f4 isn't should be your first
your first instincts you want some kind
of benoni structure I guess where you
can get at this guy but the thing is
you're really improving blacks bishop
when you play this f4 move this isn't
something you want to want to really be
doing
there's Lewis name
so yeah these are you can make some
threats but the one good thing about
this night is it does defend d6 and
really you're just gonna get kicked away
and this is gonna come anyways
yeah Michael g3 so what about g3
prevents this plan you want to pay off
for here so this is something that that
we looked at and this is something you
can consider to get you know this this
play against d6 but once again you're
really opening up blacks Bishop here in
some positions this is the way to play
for white but I don't think this
placement of pieces really is the best
option blacks ready to hop into ee5 he's
ready to use this bishop he's ready to
bring this Bishop out to this f5 square
eventually yeah g3 is interesting it's a
lot like f4 yeah
exactly that's what was played in the
game Shoji for shutting down blacks plan
and once again this is an idea that you
see from time to time in the King's
Indian but really it it's good when
black has wasted some time black has
wasted some time by playing c6 and c5 so
now white is going to take advantage of
that by playing g4 Queen h4 yeah I know
but it's worth it it's worth it in this
case so okay Queen h4 white moves this
King yeah not too much more to say
that's what happens King h8 rook g1
Queen back to e7 White was threatening
to go to g5 trapping the Queen a3 Knight
f6 b4 so now we kind of see white has
prevented f5 and so now he goes about
his plans on the Queen side at his
leisure
so black got this favorable change in
structure but white got this favorable
change in structure and so it's kind of
a battle of who got who got the better
deal from the exchange of time black
plays b6 white plays Knight e3 once
again slowly bringing his pieces to the
Queen side Knight back to g8 a for
advancing and now black finally decides
to break through with f5 so in this case
white went for g5 which is a really
interesting way to try to keep things
closed it really highlights the problem
with blacks pieces they really would
like this f6 square in this h6 Square +
g5 takes away both of those the Queen
comes to f7 a5 so once again white
commits some moves on on the Kings side
in this case but in the end it all comes
back to the Queen side that's where he's
really you know making his advantages
trying to win the game
rook b8 and we see f3 defending this
pawn giving this bishop some space h6
trying to break out a takes be a takes b
h4 not allowing black to have control of
this square f4 bishop f2 h takes g h6
Jeep and black gives up and plays Bishop
f6 from this point earlier I would say
white was definitely much better but
Bishop f6 is just it's it's too much you
can't give up the piece like this this
is what really what really lost the game
well okay but white doesn't take it you
just place your Chi - yeah so the bishop
comes back to d8 but once again the
Knights can't use this square the knight
comes to be 597 rook h2 check King g8
Bishop f1 and I mean I mean I mean I
mean like okay you know what I mean
obviously this is this is not what black
wanted so I I think white definitely has
a winning position here I'll flip
through the rest of the moves but before
we continue does it make sense how white
kind of got a winning advantage here I
flipped through this game like super
quickly and didn't explain a whole lot
of it but the key point is this is this
g4 idea g4 really locking down on this
f5 square making it a lot harder for
black to achieve his plans this is how
white chose to use his advantage in time
and then later on g5 is just some nice
understanding this isn't entirely
related to the opening but your opponent
really needs these squares so white took
them away and that's what slowed down
blacks plan further
exactly exactly
you have to understand when black goes
for something like this he's giving up
his time in exchange and so you have to
use that time in an effort to you know
do something concrete
so ninety-seven wreckage to King g8
Bishop f1 Queen g7 Knight up to a 7 so
White's really having his way with black
here just putting his Knights wherever
he wants Bishop d7 b takes c and here we
see upon sacrifice and blacks pieces are
just too bad to be able to to play
against these pawns
Knight c8 takes takes Bishop h3 and here
black resigns because he's checkmated
and these pawns are cleaning and this
works coming in and this bishops good
and these pieces are bad I think that
was enough reasons to resign but haha
yeah mainly he's checkmated after a
check check check
so in closing do you guys feel like you
learned some stuff about the Kings
Indian what do you think was unclear
this lecture anything any extra
questions you have anything you've run
into against the Kings Indian that you
were worried about switch to e4 cuz
because of the Kings Indian well now you
can switch back with confidence fair
enough fair enough okay so in closing
the main idea of this classical line
here is the c5 pawn sacrifice sidelining
black's knight and this is of course
after the main line with knight c6
so you want to sideline black's knight
and then play on the Queen side in this
game black plays for more I would say
defensive setup where he doesn't go all
out on the Kings side right away and
tries to solidify a knight on c5 once
again you want to play on the Queen side
making sure to not allow this structural
disadvantage with a3 and a4 and lastly
in this line where black wastes some
time by playing c6 and then C 5 you want
to use that X
your time to do something concrete to
slow down blacks plan in this case it
was g4 and in other cases it might be
something else you'll have to find it on
your own sometimes in chess so you have
to move the night first to defend it
mm-hmm yep well thank you all very much
for coming out tonight that'll be it
from me and join me next week on the
road to 2000s
[Music]